THDELIBLE IMAG
STORM, THE NUMBER OF BOATS OF
ALL TYPES NOT WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE, SOMER RANDY KAYE
US LAST NIGHT STI
ATED OF DOCKS AND
MOORINGS BUT WASHED INLAND BY
THE SURG
TODAY SHE MEOWNE
SUCH BOAT AND JOINS US NOW.RANDS
NTINUEDO SUC
AMAZING JOB COVERING THESTATION.
WE WERE DRIVINOU F
MYERS BE.
THE COMMUNITIESTHE FLTEHE
BOATS IN TREESES, OF COURSE.
BEA OVERAPPED
THIS WAS A MARINDING
ITEDP OUTO SEA, ED
BY THE STORM. BOAT HEK THE OTHEN
ENDEDP ONRY LAND.
WE POKTO
BOAT WHO RODE THAT STORM OUT ON
TOLD US., AND HET HE
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A S
>> RorN OT THISEEN HURRICANEG LI
HIT FORT, THE BOAT
CAPTAIN WAS IN FOR THE RIDE OF
HI>>RRY L. Reporter: MIKE HAD D.
D ME VIDEO OE
THE HURRICANE GAID
RE>> HS THE ONE YOU'LL SEE
BUILDING COLLAPSED OVETHYOU'LL
MITEYOU CAN SEE WE'RE RUNNING TN
ACTHERS THE .
SA.EVEN THAWA F WAS ONTORGE BOA5
HURRICANE IA
AT AUT ALL OF A SUDDKED UP BRCE
OF THE WATER AND THE WIN
>> WE DIDN'T ACTUALLY GE
RT ELING LIKE BEING CARRIED AL
OUT IN WATER S WE'L DANGER.E'NDO
THE WIND WAS HOWLING, AND WE  W
AND IDT KNOW WHEN WETOP.
eporter: IN THE END AFTER A
WILDS  HIS BOATSH WERE STILL TI
LANDED IN THE STREET.
AND WHILE THEY AREN'T A TOTAL
HEIAK OF THIS BOATIKE USEDOR FL
THT EVENA
WE WATCHED IT AND THE WINDS IT
GOT MORE AND MORST
PEELING THE SIDE BACK.
epORE IT RIGHT
OFF.
>>INNGAS.
ATULD END UP E KE
INSTEAD OF WAS SEA.
DID MIKE TELL YOU S TO DXT?
CAN HE SALGE OATS?
>> Reporter: HE HOPEVACTUALLY, ,
FO
BU GENOR
IT.
'S RUNNIIG,
IT BACK INTE N AS P
THIS BOAT RIGHT HERE IS EA
AGAINST A POWENE
THE POWER COMPANY WAS HERE
HE WANTS THAT BOAT IN THE WAR  Y
ASSIBLE, ANDFIX UP THE OTHER
ONE.
HE
RANDY , RY MUCH.
>>W RECEIVED WORD
STID, THATO  DEATH TOL
NOWAECK BACK I T
D A GOODHER TOWN AND THED IT
SITS ON HAD
FOR E  WAN STAY
AT TT WHAT SERVICES
IS IE? FNKTHEY D DAMAGE IS
AND KNOW, IT'S
SAY DO YOU HAVE CLEAN WATER,
LYOVERND GETTING ON TH
NDN AS WELL TOMORROWT A
BETTER ASSSM
>> AND SMITHOES
YOR, IBLE TO
GOO BEISLAND TODAY.
WHAT WAS ILIKE?
>> YOU KNOW, WATCHINAL
THAT, BUT WHENED ONTO
D YOU WA
, IT WAS -IT
T OF THE
STSLD,
GET THAT SENSE.D'T
I WENT A MOTR
UNCIL MEMBERS WI POLICE DEPARTMA
ANY LIMIOSE AREA EXTREME -- E >
>> YES, THERE ARE RIGHW.
BUT LET ME TD
G OPLEHERE A.NGO OAT TO HEA
ERE FACES THAT
WE K
AND I WA SEED THEY WERE SO GLA .
ISLAND WE ALSO SAW A
PEOPLE, ANK DOWN  WED
WE CAN MAKE  TOUST, AVE THEM MA
MIUS
AND THESWE -
THERE WERE E, YOUNGEA PREGNA ON
AND WHAT THEY WENTOUGH, E
DESCPTD WERET
TELY HORRIFIC.
>> IT MUST B A R
HES IN TO GET  YOUNOTHEM BE AYI
Y EQPMON.
ORE DO YOU KNOW ABOUT HOW AT'S
I OUTPO D?
O I HAVEN'T ANOPPORTUNITY TO SPH
ARD TO SAY CTO FIND T S THEY'RE
MANAGER WAS ON, SO IREALLY